>> HARDWICK: AND NOW IT'S TIME
TO PLAY SPACEXXX.
THE POPULAR SEXUAL INTERCOURSE
VIDEO WEB SITE PORNHUB...
IS THAT ONE? I WOULDN'T KNOW.
WHY WOULD I KNOW ABOUT A HUB OF
PORNOGRAPHY?
PORNHUB IS LAUNCHING AN
INDIEGOGO CAMPAIGN TO MAKE THE
FIRST PORNO IN SPACE...
YEAH, DO YOU KNOW WHAT THOUGH?
WAIT. JUST FUCKING WAIT. WAIT.
NOW, THEY CLAIM IT'S THE FIRST,
BUT WE CAN ONLY ASSUME THAT NASA
HAS HAD HOURS AND HOURS OF
ZERO-G SEXPERIMENTS ON TAPE
ALREADY THAT THEY'RE TOTALLY NOT
ADMITTING HAVE HAPPENED, BECAUSE
THEY WOULD HAVE TO CHECK TO SEE
IF, GOING TO MARS, YOU LOSE BONE
DENSITY.
THEY WOULD TOTALLY NEED TO KNOW
THAT.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> HARDWICK: YOU KNOW? IF
WE'RE...
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> HARDWICK: AND IF YOU DO, NOT
ONE DUDE IS EVER GONNA GO TO
MARS.
AND AT THE RISK OF WASTING ANY
MORE OF OUR VIEWERS' TIME,
COMEDIANS, IT'S, UH... IT'S PORN
IN SPACE.
YOU GUYS KNOW WHAT TO DO.
IN 60 SECONDS. AND START.
(BELL DINGS)
HODGMAN.
>> EMPIRE GOT BACK.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
(BELL DINGS)
KYLE.
>> UH... ALIEN VS. PREDATOR VS.
SOME BIG OL' TITTIES.
>> HARDWICK: FUCKING NO POINTS.
(BELL DINGS)
UH, GETHARD.
>> THE CHALLENGER EXPLODED ALL
OVER HER FACE.
(GROANING)
(CHEERING AND APPLAUSE)
>> HARDWICK: WHAT IS WRONG WITH
YOU PEOPLE?
>> I KNOW.
I SHOULD HAVE SAID "TITS."
>> YES!
>> HARDWICK: WAIT. WAIT.
WAIT, WAIT, WAIT, WAIT.
>> POINTS!
>> HARDWICK: YOUR CRITICISM ON
YOUR OWN JOKE WAS THAT YOU
SHOULD HAVE SAID "TITS"?
>> YEAH.
YEAH. IF YOU'RE GONNA DISRESPECT
A TRAGEDY...
YOU SHOULD GO...
>> YEAH, MAKE IT COUNT.
>> YEAH, YOU SHOULD GO AS-AS
DISRESPECTFUL AS POSSIBLE.
>> HARDWICK: ALL RIGHT.